foreign
[Music]
I used to do the career thing
[Music]
but
I always felt like I was feeding other
people's systems
you know there's taxes and mortgages the
electricity bill the internet bill your
new car payment or heavy rent there's
always rent
it's just there's no money nothing left
for you
can live in that lifestyle feeding all
these people's systems I'm essentially
feeding them me and I just didn't want
to go that path
[Music]
this is the only place on the whole
river where I have spotted a massive
bull moose
I only have about two days left to fill
my moose permit and secure my Winter's
cache of meat
I'm Michael Manzo I'm 37 years old
a mcmack Indian and big nomadic I live
all over Alaska
I came here when I was 20 years old and
you're not an adult when you're 20.
[Music]
I'm from Alaska I deployed three times
to Iraq
from Alaska I went to school
from Alaska I got to really push myself
and learn what I was capable of
it's literally defined who I am
[Music]
it's getting late in the season the
animals haven't been moving
it's been dry it's been hot
everything's going to be late
so if I don't seal the deal here by the
end of the season
I'm asking for trouble
there's a freedom out there that you can
grasp that you can have yourself as long
as you work hard for it and as long as
you practice and you just learn as much
as you possibly can you can have that
you ready for me
[Music]
perfect
even though Chris and Jesse Morse live
on the outskirts of the relatively small
town of Fairbanks Alaska they've had
enough of City Life their goal is to
move even further away from civilization
100 miles from the city to their
off-grid family cabin but in order to
thrive in the wild the couple must
sharpen their skills and stock up on
food before winter hits
seems like such a pain in the ass to
have to go all the way out of town just
to go Grouse up
there's fast food there's fast food
across the street is fast food there's
more fast food yeah but you are what you
eat I'm organic and Wild
well
here in town it's getting harder to hunt
I have to drive 20 miles and load up my
dirt bikes just to go grouse hunting and
get a couple growls all right the last
stop light leaving town
we've got a few more miles in this road
will end
that's my type of road yeah
we're trying to make the best of hunting
season so hopefully we'll go out and
we'll fill the freezer with some Grouse
and maybe we'll find some moose tracks
or maybe we'll find a moose
so when we get back out to our cabin we
don't have to worry about starving out
there
feels good to finally get out here it's
like just a big release a big relief off
my chest
or far enough out that there's nobody
out here and the air is fresh and you
can smell nature
this being out here just feels right
[Music]
there's a few more days left of hunting
season my goal every year is to get a
stockpile of meat
Grouse roofs in certain types of trees
and these trees look perfect I'm gonna
go kick this trees tell me if anything
moves
there should be something roosting up
there
I don't think that tree felt any of that
he said maybe you did
[Music]
all right well let's Circle back to the
dirt bikes I'm gonna try to get away
from some people get a little deeper
into the woods
all those Fresh Tracks on the road I'm
sure that the Grouse is getting scared
off
we eat out here year this is what I love
to eat it's the most organic food and in
order to stay out at the cabin for good
we need to have a freezer full of meat
this is a great place to be it's so
beautiful
but there's definitely a sense of
anticipation
just not knowing what's going to happen
all right Gilbert I need you to hop out
of the trailer so I can button up this
tarp and then we can get going
um we're not back in two days go ahead
and call the Cavalry and come looking
for us okay and uh yeah hopefully we're
successful cool
not successful you're still welcome home
oh good
love you love you too Gilbert come give
me a hug and a kiss my name is Caleb
Roland I live in McCarthy Alaska with my
wife Brittany and two children Gilbert
and elevy
you be good and you listen to Daddy and
you look for Bears
give me your dog
load up Piper
let's load up good girl
we're headed up into the heart of the
Wrangle mountains do a little bit of
subsistence hunting for black bear all
right we'll see you in a couple days
[Music]
it's soft fall time and uh would be
great to put away meat for the winter
for us harvesting an animal is really
just another way to go to the grocery
store and pick out ribeye off the shelf
but we have to be really careful there's
all sorts of external stimuli that you
have to pay attention to there's wind
weather there's other big game animals
that might want to stomp me
there's all sorts of things that can
kill me on my way to the supermarket so
I have to be really careful and keep my
wits about me
while I was dating my wife I worked in
the city for a couple years
to deal with traffic and being somewhere
every single day regardless whether I
felt like it or not
it did not take me long to realize that
that was not the life for me
I choose this lifestyle because of the
freedom
wow Gilbert this looked like a great
place to Camp don't you think
yeah let's get the gear out and get set
up
so this is my son's first trip out into
the back country overnight I believe
it's important for my son to learn some
of these skills that we're going to
learn up in the mountains today whenever
we get up to a spot like this it's very
very important that the first thing we
do is we set up our tent we get shelter
in place
hi you're calling me yep now you want to
start putting the poles on by the time I
was a teenager growing up out here I did
a fair amount out on my own
I'm looking forward to when my son can
go out and hunt on his own and help
provide for the family
you got it Gilbert good job
ah home sweet home we're gonna sleep
good tonight
sometimes I feel the need to to go back
to a a more comforting easier way of
life
but then I just sleep wake up the next
day and say wait a minute I'm Mike Manzo
I got this
it's been so warm the past few weeks
moose haven't been moving around I've
only got a few days left in the season
to get up this River locate a bull and
secure my Winter's cash and meat
but something's not quite right with my
motor
I've been doing this long enough that if
something don't feel right you stop you
check it out you don't just keep moving
you get to it as quick as you can
because you might save yourself from
some sort of a catastrophic mechanical
failure that you can't recover from
whenever I do stop I always like
throwing out a moose call
you never know
hopefully I'll get some moose
but for now
I gotta fix the problem
this is an abusive environment this is
Boulders and rocks and sweepers and log
jams
and no matter what type of equipment you
run out here you're bound to run into
mechanical problems and the key is to
just keep your cool
you just have to be mentally prepared
for the fact that things are going to
break
and if you keep your head
it actually pays out in the long run
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I have this philosophy that uh the
animal gives itself to you
I truly believe if you're respectful to
the landscape animal respects you enough
it gives itself to you and that's what
happened a big body bull
ET healthy that shot was good
[Music]
right there
huge animal
unbelievable how big these are
this ain't some cow
sitting around in the Midwest
eating a bunch of corn that he's not
even genetically predisposed to eat
and then he goes up a line gets a spike
in his head
his Spirit ain't even respected he's
just a a trapped animal
that rope is slipping a little bit but
it's not bad
this moose whose big strong healthy he
lived Wild
and he had a choice because he walked
right there to me
gave himself to me
[Music]
I got a big job ahead of me cutting this
moose up and loading him in the canoe by
myself
it's easily going to be a six seven hour
job
but I gotta get this thing done
all right
[Music]
all right I think I'm ready to cut a at
least a front quarter off this moose
there it is
[Music]
I woke up one day and just started
confidently rejecting or having an
allergic reaction to expensive things
things that I felt were just
unsustainable with the typical wages
were paid
oh
there's the neck oh
that's a heavy ass chunk of meat
I just feels sad for a lot of people who
are feeding all these these wealthy
middlemen all these systems they've
sculpted the cost of living around us
and we just have to accept it
so it's more of a looking around and
saying hey I don't need to have this
city or expensive things to be happy
foreign
Ty is kind of what I thrive on in a lot
of ways it's my biggest nemesis
but it's also I think what draws me to
this lifestyle
it's only getting colder every day so I
think we need to get this Edition put on
here for both us
and the dog's sake
my name is Brent sass I'm a professional
dog musher and I've been mushing for 13
years
foreign
Eureka on Joe Bush Creek with 60 sled
dogs my girlfriend Eda and we Libby
breed and sleep sled dogs
the general game plan is to double the
cabin I built this cabin three years ago
for myself
it's a pretty small cabin and since Eden
moved in a year and a half ago we've
known that it's definitely needs an
addition so that we could have some more
space for her to sort of be able to have
a space that she can call her own
it's my second full winter season here
in Eureka with friends and the dogs
in my life before Eureka I was living
the city life and I came to realize that
it just wasn't for me
so where do we start the first step and
the most important one is to get it
attached and then we can build from
there
winter looming Brent and Eda must race
the clock to complete the cabin
extension
the addition must be done before
snowfall and dropping temperatures
render construction projects impossible
we're doing things alone really sucks
and it's really nice to have someone
just to hold that
Eureka is 150 miles from Fairbanks
there's no resources
there's no power grid we're on our own
that one's got to be seven inches you
know they're about two feet apart I'm
still not good at the feet metric is
where it's at
in the last few months we've actually
talked a lot about how I can kind of own
this lifestyle a little bit more so this
is a process that we're going through in
our relationship and in life here making
everything more balanced and responsible
for a lot more
I have to come out of my shell a bit
more and and stand up for myself and be
strong
is that window the exact same size as
this other one
because it would look funny to have it
at a different height
I'm just I'm just asking do you think it
would look funny I don't really get what
it looks like
the way that my life worked for you know
25 years of my independent life was I
made my own decisions I didn't think of
anybody else when I made the decisions
but when you involve someone else in
your life there has to be some
compromise on both sides it's a dance
and it's not very easy
if you want the window lower then we
should make the window lower this is
your final call because I can still cut
those off
can't you just get up there can you come
out with me and look at it sure
not gonna get my wall done in a half
hour now
I'm not great with making decisions in
general I trust friends he's pushing me
to make make decisions and to be part of
everything lower it by like half a foot
okay does that yeah that makes sense to
me
and it starts with a window sometimes
in town there's laws there's government
there's things you can and can't do
out in the woods it's up to me
it's really important why we're here in
town that we go out we get some hunting
done we really want to fill our freezers
and get all set up for winter
you got to be real careful living out in
the bush dangers are around every corner
worst case scenario is starving to death
I want to hop off here and check this
out it looks pretty grousy here
I really need some practice with my bow
because I'm just starting out
the Grouse are absolutely perfect target
practice
so you go ahead and go on the left side
and I'm going to come in on the right
and I'll see what I can see
you see anything jazz
I'm gonna kick some trees left yeah
nothing huh
[Music]
oh I see him really yeah come
he's a great place
oh my God
you kidding me
I've got to figure out how to get a
grouse in a tree this is absolutely a no
promise yeah but you know if you aim a
little lower don't try to hit like the
top of it I didn't bring my gun out for
some reason
it's like straight up yeah it's gonna be
a hard shot
it's a hard one you got this love
the Grouse is right there sitting not
moving staring straight at me this is my
chance to get the grouse
foreign
two
all right three
two
[Music]
down I lost the arrow and I didn't get
the word
I really wanted to get the scrows I want
to get better
the thing is is when I go out to the
cabin there's not going to be an ammo
store so I need something sustainable
and that's arrows
I don't know what to do about this site
and I stinking whacked my arm with it
damn
need to keep hunting I need to keep
getting my skills better
because winter is coming
I like that here in McCarthy I can get
on my four-wheeler and in five minutes
be in world class hunting area or hiking
you name it whatever it is it is world
class
[Music]
it's a good day for game to be out
moving
out it looked it after we looked like
not to move right down here that's a cow
moose you got good eyes Gilbert I don't
know very many five-year-olds that would
be able to spot those down there we're
gonna leave the Moose alone it's a
little too late in the season for that
but it gives me a good feeling about the
day just need to exchange those Moose
for a bear
harvesting game the way we do is not
your average trip to the supermarket so
sometimes you have to change up your
game plan and go look from new places
and find out where they're hiding
all right Gilbert we're in hunting camp
which means you got to be talking a
little bit quieter
this hunt does bring back memories of
when I was younger getting a hike
through the woods hunting with my father
I hope that my son will take all these
lessons he's learned to heart and in the
near future he'll be able to come out
and experience the Wilderness by himself
but you got to be careful we have bears
in the woods here and it's prudent of
you to be mindful of your surroundings
making sure you cover your bases on just
simple stuff like going on a walk
see what I see
it looks like a big pile of bear scat
looks pretty fresh I'd say it's probably
a good good spot to sit in glass for a
little bit
growing up as a teenager out here I
didn't appreciate it for what it was and
I always swore I would never come back
but just a couple years of life in the
city and I realized what I was missing
and it was coming back as an adult that
I then actually fell in love with this
place
it's getting pretty late in the day and
uh starting to look like we might be
skunked
from all that time in war
but uh I ain't nowhere is near a
Breaking Point yet I'm still chugging
along and I'm keeping the tempo up
and I think that this is the time that I
got a blast home because this meat does
have an expiration date on it
but uh I'm a little stressed out right
now to have my main engine go down
so where the issue is
the prop is moving
but it's no longer connected to the
motor
and I don't know where that problem is
when you break down here in the middle
of nowhere
it's not as convenient as calling around
asking your friends and family hey do
you know a cheap mechanic
out here there's no roads you know I
can't just walk out of here and go get
the parts I am essentially immobile
that's why I bring a spare motor
and I just swap usable parts and just
fix it up
you'll have these moments to where
Alaska really hands you your ass
and I do have stresses bouncing around
from location location but you just
learn to accept it and get a little more
resourceful
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
took about an hour
to see this repair through but this is
the moment of truth
I'm back in business
foreign
so now that this repair was successful
all that's left is to break down camp
and get everything loaded up and get
this moose meat home
being fairly nomadic I feel like my life
has always been
was just on on the Run
here in Alaska landscape is so vast
and I just haven't found that one spot
yet where I say hey I want to stop
moving maybe someday I'll find that
place that takes my breath away
until then I'm enjoying the change of
the scenery the change of the landscape
so now the next Lake begins pushing this
heavily loaded boat
through a very technical River
it's a big load this is what I got to do
in this neck of the woods to feed myself
and it is a little bit more involved
than going to the grocery store and
grabbing a shopping cart and going
around and reading the back of the
labels and wondering what natural flavor
is and looking for MSG and your food
making sure there ain't that you know
this is a lot simpler there's one
ingredient moose
foreign
[Music]
getting hurt up on the Mountainside is
just not an option
and I do my best to make sure that it
isn't an option
[Music]
I'm getting the morning going this
morning cooking a little bit of
breakfast here yesterday we woke up
bright and early
glassed all day but we didn't see
anything we're gonna make uh one last
ditch effort
if there's anything there we'll Harvest
it if not uh we'll head on home
part of the goal of this trip is to put
away meat for the winter but just
getting out with my son in the back
country and teaching him camping skills
we'll make the trip a success all on its
own
black bears are a fairly elusive animal
they're hard to hunt they're not at the
top of the food chain so they're
constantly watching their back we're
gonna head down the mountain about
halfway down there's another Trail I can
take to another Valley that we've seen
bears in before
all these things that he's been learning
on this trip are things that he will be
able to apply in the future to be more
self-sufficient
more independent
and a contributing member of society
jump from Rock to rocks you don't get
all wet okay makes hiking miserable
[Applause]
that was my children to be a light to
society and not a drain
I finally made it up onto this Ridge
pretty fantastic vantage point
we've got Kennecott Glacier down here
with the root Glacier feeding in
and presiding over all of this Glacier
here is the Blackburn Mountain
well this may be a tough way to gather
food for our freezer for the winter time
being able to stand where I am right now
and enjoy this
beautiful view
makes the strenuous work totally worth
it
you see anything Gilbert I did not see
Annie I see a lot of empty Green Field
out there
we probably covered 10 square miles of
ground here and we have not seen
anything it's not looking too good for
success
ultimately it would be great to harvest
a black bear to bring home but just
being out in the wilderness experiencing
it with my son is more than enough
satisfaction to me
it's getting kind of late in the day so
uh what do you say we head home
all right let's pack up and go
foreign
for a lot of people and and it
definitely was for Edo when when she
came here
it is it is the rainbow times 10 living
here
[Music]
in the last few days we've been working
on this addition to our cabin that we
live in and it's been really exciting to
see it come to life
there
the addition is going to be really uh
awesome for both of us so I'm super
stoked that we can make this happen and
I'm super stoked that she can help build
this thing she needs to learn some of
these skills that I have so that she can
help in in future building projects that
will always be building projects
now you can put insulation cutter on
your resume
I have so many friends back home that
are looking at me like what the heck is
going on what happened to you
they hear that we're this far removed
from town and we're off the power grid
and water grid they really have such a
hard time understanding how I'm
comfortable with it
hey Eda
do you think you come up here for a
little bit
[Music]
not fall down is that ladder safe
hyper definitely not my favorite thing
I just need your help lifting up on the
lip
you okay
I know this isn't your favorite so only
stand on the wood yep
obviously because if you stand there
you're gonna go into the building
Heights is a big thing for you to
she is overcoming obstacles in her life
which is huge okay yeah so now if you
can just push that all the way down go
down to the end and I'll push it here
and you'll lift it up over there
so I step on that yeah yeah
that went a lot easier than I thought it
was gonna be
okay let's put some metal on
you make it this is not the favorite
thing I thought you're doing it
okay I'm doing a
thank you for being a good sport that
was good that helped
yielding strong enough to do all the
things I wanted to do on my own so it
means a lot to go from not feeling
confident to being a person that just go
out and do what needs to be done and I
can fully trust that I got this
all right well we got the roof on just
in time huh it started to snow I'll put
the walls in and get the the interior
plywood done
well we better get going on this project
or it's going to be
winter before we know it so
I don't take days off I don't not work
winter is around the corner the
temperatures are dropping it's barely
getting above freezing during the day it
certainly is becoming harder and harder
to do construction projects
and we kind of squeeze this thing in
right as winter was about to come and
everything gets a lot harder
[Music]
good job yeah got on the roof even
[Laughter]
once you get this Alaskan landscape in
your blood it gets in there and it
sticks
foreign
fun it's about choosing the safest path
the water is cold
the boat is heavily loaded
it ain't over till it's over
the Final Phase of this trip is slowly
taking this big load home this is a
river full of sweepers Boulders shallow
riffles
and you have to somehow navigate around
that stuff and just basically thread
that heavily loaded boat through that
section
change in some of the rocks that I could
see are now ever so slightly submerged
all right up here I see the signature of
a rock
there it is ready to break a hole in
something
you could barely make it out
I feel like the liquid road is more real
than the asphalt road
Alaska is one of the last great
wildernesses left it's very powerful to
be in a freighter canoe On A Wild River
and I take it and I push it and myself
to the limits
[Music]
this is why I left the city
I do appreciate unhindered places
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
work for me is how I know that I've done
it it's it's my goal if my arms are sore
and I have a big load of firewood you
know I I've made it I feel good about
myself
um and that's that's what I crave every
single day I'm after that
there's lots of cranberries picked clean
someone's been walking this
I just wanted to check these guys out
right here yeah
we're just not ready to give up quite
yet oh that was a good Shake
damn
there should be stinking grass
everywhere
all right well let's Circle back up to
the bikes
rejecting the convenience of fast food
in the city
Chris and Jesse Morse will need to
source as much wild meat as they can in
order to make it through winter once
they move full time to their family's
off-grid cabin there is
don't go too much farther
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I got it
[Music]
I can't really see where he went but
there he is
where is he
right there
oh yeah
we can't afford to lose the animal if
I'm going to take the first shot he's
going to be the backup
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but let's meet in the fridge
here's our Grouse good job love
there's quite a learning curve to this
whole type of Lifestyle I did lose a
arrow
so that Grouse cost me 16 bucks
but I'll get better and then it won't
cost me anything right
I'm trying to take the things that I've
learned from City Life and things that
I've learned from the internet that my
parents never had and I'm taking all of
this knowledge out to the bush and I'm
melding these two worlds
[Music]
there's so many things out at the cabin
that you can't really plan for or expect
there's a lot of unsafe stuff out of the
cabin I mean I don't have a hospital I
don't have a grocery store and I can't
go to a mechanic the only person that's
going to be able to fix it is my husband
or myself
every day I've got to adapt every day
I've got to learn something new
to be on point if you let yourself down
you're letting the entire household down
so trusting your partner is something
you really have to learn to do
[Music]
stand back
we're going into our second winter
together here Eden and I we're going to
be faced with a whole new set of
challenges
it's just a big curveball every year for
me and she's going into her second
season and and so she's got to learn
that like it's never it's never going to
be easy
hi hello
wow yeah look at that
what do you think guys huh we just made
the connection go on Carver this might
only be my second year out here and I
know that I have lots to learn
we can hang out over here
but we're in this together and I'm not
I'm not giving up so we'll see what the
future brings
[Music]
oh are you ready for your food can you
push that over here
okay do you want to pray or do you want
Mommy to all right well
the only father thank you for this yummy
food thank you for the most that we got
a few weeks ago this blessed to our
buddies and help us all to have a good
night with good attitudes amen
if you'd asked me five years ago if I
would ever want to leave McCarthy and
live in the city my answer would have
been definitely whenever Caleb's ready
but my husband is building us this
beautiful house and I want to give my
kids a healthy better life and in town
they would end up having a lot busier of
a childhood than the slow easy one that
they get to have out here
after all this planning and preparing
all these obstacles on the river this
right here is the payoff from all that
hard work
the dark the cold is coming upon us
and now the piercing blast of winter is
coming in
I don't always know what's around the
bend of the River of Life
and I like that way I like the great
mystery
oh my goodness look at that
golden brown
oh man it's just my mouth is watering
[Music]
it just tastes like hard work
Love Me Again
show me
[Music]
[Music]